[Music]
in his watch has ended news submitted by
Jake from State Farm [ __ ] shape Kit
Harington has checked into a luxury
rehab for stress and alcohol because the
show ended so he's fine John snow from
Game of Thrones I know you don't watch
Game of Thrones do you know what the
name of the center is called you will
always be my queen you talking about Kit
Harington yes he's sad cuz his life is
done miss Carrington oh this dude yeah
yeah poor dude isn't he married
listen going through what's the evil
ugly Ygritte yeah yeah oh really that's
his real wife I realize their chemistry
was amazed he fell in love and they got
married you know what was [ __ ]
disgusting on the show is when they
first had sex yay - [ __ ] out and they
were [ __ ] dirty as [ __ ]
oh that must have been musty ass [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] disgusting you know what
he probably did he got he got snow and
then he whitewashed it off yeah she
didn't know weren't they in that they
were in the cave it was that was like a
little hot so they didn't think about
first no I think they just wish straight
to [ __ ] that's like public info like
he told that story no it's in the show
dang with your mouth don't snow oh yeah
that you always be much he is staying at
the luxury Connecticut health retreat
called previous with see it's a hell -
retreat I hate on people get something
and twist the [ __ ] words around he's
a [ __ ] alcohol rehab place where they
specialize on alcohol
and like people successful people that
have I feel like they have no purpose in
life exactly that's what I'm talking
about it's more of like a a mindfulness
wellness that's wellness clinic yes look
when I first read this article I was
kind of I felt bathroom because well
number one I'm a fan but the number two
people that happened quickly haven't
done things at an extreme level I don't
think they understand the light the down
that you feel right so like when when
special-ops dudes when they come back
for more it's very normal to get
debriefed and it's a brief case like
they tell you okay like these are the
things that this is how any loose ends I
need to be tied up in your brain okay we
didn't kill that guy this guy or
whatever rules of engagement when you
come back you need to go back to your
families like there's a lot of things
that help you back down right so
anything at a high level whether it's
sports movie stars or anything when
you're like up here yeah presidency JK
news you need to get debriefed and
slowly come back down so you don't just
like feel like you're on top of the
world and then the next - yeah so for
this to me this is like a very normal
thing I'm like this is that's dope I
like how how he checked himself in so he
can kind of slowly transition back into
normal life after you've been on top I
understand but I think a lot of people
they see it not oh my god he's an
alcoholic online oh yeah they like he
save their shame that he's in the clinic
predominantly for stress and exhaustion
and also alcohol because you depend hue
realize like he became very dependent on
alcohol so he does have an alcohol it
just sounds like a normal Korean father
dude like I don't understand what it
sounds like my uncle did I feel like he
he's depressed cuz the show's done it
he's gone that's exactly why he's in
there because we hate years yeah yeah
well they said eight years imagine how
Jaleel White Bell when they ended family
matters oh yeah yeah you needed
something like this too so he's been
there for
Harry Potter boy yeah he would say [ __ ]
like this too he actually did do it good
the character dies so does your soul
yeah Harry Potter and then also the guy
the guy for a mad mad mad mad men oh the
man John yeah you also don't have to go
to rehab for this ain't like a similar
thing what about the cast to save on a
bit of a leading man right oh dude that
was right on top of the world they need
something like this it's also like
particularly though for like this
specific problem so it's they're calling
it like the curse of the leading man
right so you have this show that has a
really long run you're supposed to be
portraying this very like strong man
that's like the lead role and then it
takes up a chunk of your life
mm-hmm someone that when it ends men in
particular because they're the ones well
I think this makes really hard sense
because there's people who need to be
debriefed and they have this [ __ ] in
their lives like you know like those
high school guys they're like do you
remember high school like do you need me
debrief or your high school glory you
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up dude so people
like that feel it I can only understand
what they're going through
that's pretty crazy yeah so you stole a
football really hard in high school
this facility do you guys want to guess
how much it cost her my million dollars
in dollars hmm million okay everyone's
at the same time no good twenty thirty
thousand I already know cuz I read I
read and I talked you already know i
would i would guess i might I be like
50k so you guys know it's 120 thousand
that's so much wait a minute does it
come with a harem of women that it's
willing to suck you dry
who the [ __ ] is the word harab they
had so they have services that include
acupuncture Pilates and for infrared
sauna treatments yoga therapeutic
massages and private villas with
housekeeping fine linens and information
he can literally do all that at home for
less than 120 no that's
hisses but obviously like so he has been
undergoing psychological coaching
practicing mindful meditation and
cognitive behavioral therapy to combat
stress and deal with negative emotions
and also like his apology is that why he
just keeps does he just walk around
still talking like Jon Snow tell em what
you were read about you read about this
[ __ ] yeah going into town mm-hmm know
how he was like he never wanted to be
the lead Oh
like I never wanted to be the Queen John
died oh yeah it's up for him he got
stressed out after like the stress he
started the stress came from this yeah
after he died and then came back to life
because then the show kind of revolved
around him heavily he wanted to just die
cast it was Game of Thrones right like
more ensemble cast you're like a fan of
everybody but after he died and came
back to life the spot like kind of be
focus was on him cuz now he's like the
chosen one in the show no one else has
gone through something like that so now
he was like [ __ ] now I'm carrying the
weight of the show I don't want to be
the star of the show I just want to be
like everyone else
he should have been relieved with the
season finale because it led nowhere for
him though he said like so okay let me
read to second writers you stupid ass so
he said my darkest period was when the
show seemed to become so much about John
when he died and came back I really
didn't like the focus of the whole show
coming in on to John when you become a
cliffhanger of a TV show and a TV show
probably at the height of its power the
focus on you is [ __ ] terrifying that
was a time when I started therapy and
started talking to people I had felt
very unsafe and I wasn't talking to
anyone and then he's saying that after
filming the final scenes for Game of
Thrones that's when he had a full-on
breakdown because when they but when
they called a wrap he just broke down
and when he had to go and take the
costume off he said that he said that he
was he felt like he was being skinned
well yeah like this character like he
became John that they were ripping off
this character from him and it just felt
like she was being skinned
oh you could just beat John every day
for no reason take the costume how old
is he our whole disease
now 32 so he was 22 right or like 30
degree okay
I keep thinking - well I think I think
the show was shot over ACS those eight
years but there was time for it to be
released so technically his production
is probably a long time skip a year -
that's true but yeah because they're
saying that he played John Snow for
eight years
all right right it was like ten years he
was a baby he was 22 years old so that's
like and he met his wife there - like
it's like although that like brand -
like he was a baby Arya was like how old
like [ __ ] my god I bet you what he
[ __ ] his wife he's doing is Jon Snow a
hundred percent now little you think he
has enough money to get in the costume
go to [ __ ] Norway go up in the ice
and just bone his wife there yeah we
about his life as a wildling and then
they're reporting that Rosa's being
lovely roses her name
that lovely sorry miss penguin huh okay
Ygritte is being so extremely supportive
cuz she's sad too
cuz he's [ __ ] shot his ass holes and
arrows [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not a love though I bet you they
they cried together about the show did
you guys see the last watch no I haven't
seen that yet ah that documentary it's
really clear and this really did I did
for that viral clip there he cried
that's probably what he was feeling like
he was getting his skin ripped off his
body that's why he was crying no you
cried when he found out he kills cuz
we're doing a cable read like the
[ __ ] read I know I saw that one as
I'm saying oh yeah yeah and then he read
they're supposed to kill Daenerys
I was like that's why I see now it all
makes sense I'll say why doesn't [ __ ] is
he crying or something I've heard in
years
yeah he was crying like he was actually
him now it makes sense yeah he didn't
remove himself yeah he was crying as if
he was actually killing him and it was
all of them more though like I know it
was just him you bawling like a little
[ __ ]
no even uh more fair
his character when he found out he died
yeah he wanted a cry too then he like
kind of through the script a little bit
so he was like whoa I can't believe I'm
dead now yeah but he went Club but he
was like bit oh you're like convulsing a
little bit like okay dude relax dude
well anyway what are your thoughts on
the finale I told I poke it in it in
this room there's two people that I wish
becomes crown spoiler if you didn't
watch it [ __ ] you
I want either terian or bran terian but
that's not that's not the reason why
people were upset in yeah technically if
you want to break the wheel it makes
sense that bran would be a king but they
did not lead up the story to make it
that way they even gave him a line where
he said he is not a person anymore he
doesn't want anything because he's a
three-eyed Raven yeah you've supposed to
have no title yet that line was weird
cuz just like why you think I'm here for
exactly that's that doesn't make sense
with what you let up for the past year
why does everyone listen to [ __ ]
Tyrion all of a sudden he's the one shut
up all right wait I speak for a little
bit 10 minutes straight anyone's thank
you uh and then now bran all of a sudden
I was so [ __ ] cookie makes the right
time you actually liked it though right
I like the way it ended yeah but did I
like how you could get caught up in the
minutia but then if you if you look at
the macro right the best way to end the
game of Thrones is to give it to a
person who will end the game of Thrones
right but I wish they would have just
set it up a little bit yeah but like
like I said like so nobody's mad that
bran is the king they're mad man it
didn't make sense for him to be it they
could have let I buy them right way if
John was the king how predictable is
that it would have been not I think
people just mad that brands the King not
that John's not the king they're mad
because in who else would
they were just thrown out the window
Game of Thrones has never been about the
king that would have made more sense so
Game of Thrones has never been about
like the ending it's always been about
the means so how you got there is so far
more saying there wasn't enough
development behind Brandt's character
was lazy it was just so [ __ ] rushed
and they were just like you know what
let's just shut everyone up and let's
just [ __ ] them because I feel like a
lot of like I already told like I said
this is gonna be any when I started
watching the show the show was hyper
predictable for me so after a while I
stopped caring about the end it was how
are you gonna get to this point
cuz for me I had a feeling Brandon was
gonna be king but they weren't leading
anywhere to uh Saul's like I guess he
won't be yeah so like the even the plot
twist doesn't make any sense cuz he
literally stated he's just a three-eyed
Raven and that's his position then he
goes why do you think I've been doing
this whole thing but there's where did
you war to where the [ __ ] did you war -
they didn't [ __ ] answer that part
either on top of that - [ __ ] Cersei
and a [ __ ] TV Jamie came back and I'm
like so they could have survived it they
just [ __ ] move ten feet this is I
don't think I didn't like how the Hound
died - I thought that was stupid with
his brother yeah the weight and kind of
like how they developed I got that one
now it made sense but how they developed
his brother and his his hate
relationship they didn't really
highlight it that much aside from the
fact that it was a peace note in his
past where he hated his brother so the
fact that his brother snapped out of it
and started fighting him was a little
odd for though that was the way he liked
Cersei commanded him and then he was
just like [ __ ] you that's the first time
he ever broke Circe's command yeah that
was really weird
it was very odd I might have his on all
of a sudden what do you get so hard when
Cersei left
she was she's like okay I'm the last
episode nasty for me well I hope you
never watch it yeah I probably won't
spoil brainier that stuff nothing with
bran saying that line uh why do you
think I came all the way here
that means you let all those innocent
people die this whole time justly could
become king
she was an evil person in the world it's
like and you know what's another dumb
line he goes have you found the dragon
they're like oh it might be over he goes
alright I'll go find it then and I still
don't know where the [ __ ] he went when
the White Walkers I'm a trip right now
oh we're gonna answer that
[ __ ] he just got his drones and he
was watching the whole thing that [ __ ]
was so [ __ ] fun he goes hey branch
it's about to go down he goes oh really
you gotta watch the show understand what
we're talking about dude I feel like I
haven't heard people talk about him more
than when it was bad yeah
so maybe that was kind of a good day but
the writing was so good before it's just
it's funny because I even though people
are talking more about it now
I feel less inclined to watch it cuz I
want to talk about how much it ended up
bad kind of like what happened lost so
good I lost everybody was into it and
then it wrote itself into a corner and
then people like don't bother but I did
hear about yeah right I immediately
thought of lost when I lost didn't make
any sense towards the last couple nights
and that's what makes you not want to
watch any of I already was because of
the writers strike during that it was it
was the run yeah yeah so they were lazy
writing but now you know because the
game of Thrones
it wasn't right like that queer
[Music]